[Music]
so um right so this uh this talk is
scalability but at what cost
I don't know people he practically this
was a meme you know a few years ago it
was originally the work was sort of
started by Michael is our Derek Murray
and myself you'll you'll hear the story
but basically had some free time to kill
and I wanted to look at a few things
about distributed systems we had built
some and we had some opinions and we
decided we were in a position to write a
fairly opinionated paper a position we
hadn't been in before so we we did that
a lot of what I'm gonna tell you are
let's say opinions are biased you might
disagree with some of the conclusions
that's great we can talk about it
don't make any financial investments
based on what you hear here but just
take take what I tell you put it in your
brain and decide if it's if it's gonna
be helpful for you so let's see this is
the sort of thing that started
everything off from our from our point
of view this is some data from a paper
in 2014 so it's a little too little
outdated now the results here the
system's involved gotten better but the
the issue the core issue was still a
problem this is a paper the graphics
paper where the graphics authors were
looking at large-scale graph processing
so what sorts of computations can we do
on graphs relatively large graphs these
graphs have billions of edges in them
across different you know different
systems with many many cores 100 of
course and this case they're looking at
graphic connectivity all right so which
which nodes in your graph can reach
other nodes
in your graph following a traversal of a
bunch of edges potentially and you look
at the numbers and their number you know
like it sure seems that things get
better as you go down right graphics
really you know it's pretty pretty solid
compared to GraphLab a purpose-built
graph processing system but graphics is
sort of friendly and and you know lives
in the spark ecosystem so that's nice
you get get some good good trade-offs
and basically you know these numbers
look pretty pretty pleasant they fit
with the narrative of you know systems
work is moving forward now graph
connectivity how many people do graph
connectivity regul
Yeah right that's okay fair enough so
I'm gonna give you a little primer on
the algorithm that is being used in
these systems to do graph connectivity
just you know don't don't worry too much
about the specific details here I'm
gonna sketch what's going on so one way
to figure out in a graph who's connected
to whom is is the following you start
you give every node in the graph a label
typically its own name so if the if the
nodes are numbered 0 up through number
of nodes label every one initially with
their own name 0 1 2 and what we're
gonna do is repeatedly until this this
stabilizes repeatedly look at every edge
in the graph and look at the labels on
the the two ends of the graph and if
they're different we're gonna take the
larger of the labels and override it
with the smaller of the labels all right
so as as we run this over and over again
essentially the small labels in the
graph flow through the graph and and in
each component the smallest label will
eventually take over the entire
component it'll stick and we will have
assuming the labels were different when
we started we'll have all of the
connected components identified by their
label right basically what's going I
didn't want to walk you through the code
but you can sort of see if you've been
reading along that does the same thing
so not only is this a nice hunk of
pseudocode describing label propagation
its actual code it's rustic code and you
can run it on my laptop so we did these
data sets all fit comfortably in main
memory on my laptop they're between 6
and 15 gigabytes but yeah but they fit
so we can add another line here if we
wanted new system called laptop it's got
it's got one core at his disposal and
you know you get numbers like this which
might be a bit potentially surprising we
thought they were surprising actually we
didn't think they were surprising but we
thought the audience would think they
were surprising now so this raises some
questions and we'll get to those
questions but before we get to those
questions for all of you out there who
didn't raise your hand when you were
doing graph connectivity let me reveal
that label propagation is not a good way
to compute
graph connectivity it fits really nicely
in these scalable frameworks because
there's a lot of parallel work to do you
pick up all these edges totally
independently and you look and you see
who's connected to to whom locally but
it's a very bad algorithm they're better
algorithms this algorithm called Union
fine that you learn in undergrad
computer science yes sir it dates back
to the 70s or 80s and if you implement
that it's it's one additional line of
code and it knocks off an order of
magnitude from your running times so you
know we've taken what's essentially the
undergraduate level computer science
written 10 to 15 lines of code and we're
now running you know 10 to 20 X faster
than these distributed systems are
running on a hundred times the resources
which is a bit you know there's some
existential angst that shows up at this
point if you're a sort of person who
builds and uses these distributed
systems you got a like sort out
fundamentally like you know what went
wrong how did we get to this state where
our systems are not actually faster on
these problems than a naive you know
sort of one-off computation on and
roughly our take our analysis was that
the systems community and people using
these systems as their fetishized
scalability scalability is really
exciting like if I have scalability then
eventually I'll become Google right
because they have they have scalability
and we're talking earlier about
causality and it doesn't work this way
but mistaking scalability which is a fun
ability means it's a tool for doing
something for performance which is what
you actually want to get you want to be
able to do things with your system that
you couldn't previously do maybe on your
laptop and you're hoping the scalability
would get you there and the question is
does scalability actually get you to
what you would have been able to do with
your you know your workstation or your
laptop so we came up with a way of
thinking about it's not a earth shaking
shaking lee new way of thinking about
this but this picture will hopefully
clear things up here these are two
actual scaling curves for two systems
GraphLab and Nyad now it's a system that
I I was involved in when I was at
Microsoft Research and this this
particular problem is doing
iterations of PageRank on the Twitter
craft so as you add more cores both
systems get better if you're interested
in scalability you might say that well
you know and I had seems like it sort of
chokes a little earlier right who knows
what's gonna happen at 512 it might
actually be worse than graphing who
knows right which is exciting to think
about if what you're excited about is
scalability but I'm gonna put another
measurement on here which hopefully will
clarify some things which is the single
laptop implementation how long does it
take to do iterations of PageRank and it
draws quite literally a distinction
between these two curves where the lower
line is is actually important improving
on your laptop it takes a little while
take 16 cores before we're actually
improving on a tuned single machine
implementation but that's fundamentally
different from the other line where at
least in these data grabs lab has since
improved and been acquired by Apple for
200 million dollars so you know we can
afford to make some jokes you know they
don't actually reach this line is that
interesting I mean what's what's well
fundamentally we thought the thing that
was interesting was looking at or
identifying for each of these systems
the configuration that outperforms a
single thread where's the the point in
their scaling curves where they actually
hit this laptop line I'm gonna call this
the cost
so for nayad there be a cost of 16 cores
and for graft lab in this case about 512
basically they have some data not in
their scaling measurements that show
that they can beat this this line and
again since since their paper was
published they've improved done more
engineering but they mean the gist of
this is that you should ask this about
systems that scaling measurements up
above the laptop line they're pretty
pretty uninteresting right I mean I
could build a distributed system that is
my laptop plus as many cores as you want
to give me and I'll put those cores
we'll play video games the mind bitcoin
don't care right so I can I can make
that curve up above the laptop look
however I can make it look like a sine
wave if you want because it's all extra
fluff that I'm just parallelizing the
laptop is the only work you actually
needed to do so you know we're trying to
sort of focus attention I guess on the
region below the laptop how does your
system look once it's actually better
than what you had before so this results
in some some slightly awkward curves so
some systems out there it's a log scale
by the way on the y-axis
they just they don't meet the the
single-threaded benchmark and this may
be fine right you may have to come up
with a different reason why you'd want
to use this system and there are other
good reasons you know your laptop can't
I'm not actually advocating that people
should use a laptop definitely not my
laptop for your computation but it's
worth thinking about you know why why
are we are we using this because we're
gonna go fast what's the deal so there's
been some responses to this that's good
I mean we're mostly trying to start
trouble you know we were trying to get
people talking about what's going on
with these systems and there's as I said
there are plenty of good reasons that
you might be interested in doing these
things so when one very common class of
response I'm gonna work through a few of
them but one of the common ones was
amateur you know a billion edges isn't
big data you need you know if you can
run it on your laptop we're
fundamentally not interested in that you
know it's a fair complaint on the
surface of it I just throw up some data
someone asked that and then like within
a week I'd pulled down the common crawl
data which has about a hundred and
twenty eight billion edges in it so it's
about a terabyte on disk and laptop
happily processes that just fine as well
it's you know it's getting close so I
don't want to be too smug here and these
measurements as far as I'm aware don't
exist for graphics don't exist for SPARC
in that these systems basically run out
of memory at the limit of those graphs
we saw previous slides that Twitter in
the UK graph their JVM base they use a
lot of memory and if you use more memory
than you've got on your computer you
configure your JVM with things just shut
down well shut down but but these
systems are fault tolerant so they'll
start up again then they'll shut down
and which okay so you know point number
two maybe your laptop doesn't have fault
tolerance that's absolutely true and
that could not have been clearer than
last night when we had no power or
internet access so you know bear that
for them on you know your laptop isn't
gonna give you multi-site resilience or
anything like that on the other hand you
do have to worry about you know whether
this is the tail wagging the dog or not
right people build systems with hundreds
of machines in them if the only reason
they're using so many machines is to
recover the performance that they lost
in making things fault-tolerant it feels
like you might be on the wrong end of a
vicious cycle right if the system would
finish in one tenth of the time using
1/100 the resources maybe you don't need
the fault tolerance right in in a big
data batch computation setting fault
tolerance is fundamentally a performance
optimization right you can always
restart the computation and fault
tolerance just tries to get you to the
answer faster is it actually doing that
or not is a excellent question to make
sure that you know the answer to
enterprise integration is important and
this is absolutely a hundred percent
correct right like my laptop is not you
know compliant with various official
it's not GD PR compliant or anything
like that
I don't have HDFS adapters on my final
system these things are important to do
and you should absolutely be happy to
use systems that have them but this
really has nothing to do with
scalability right you could turn on
Hadoop or SPARC and just do a single
slot worker that pulls in all the data
does all the work in that one thread and
then exits in the time that I just
showed you you don't necessarily need to
use a big data system for that you just
need to use these systems as task
launchers which you know is it's a good
thing you know if you don't want to have
to do that stuff for yourself paying
someone else to do it
very very good but don't don't get
yourself tied up in knots necessarily
trying to use the graph branded
subsystem there are a lot of comments of
this forum author probably isn't very
smart
you know off there probably doesn't know
how to use spark which I think was there
these were probably typed by various
people who did understand spark pretty
well or at least paid a few thousand
dollars to do be told that fair enough I
mean we took the numbers from Reynold
and from Joey the the actual authors of
these systems so and also I'm the guy
with the curve below the line so draw
your own conclusions the dual to this
the thing the answer that I liked the
most we got a few of these there a lot
of people who came back and said
basically thank you like I sorry as the
person typing I saw the similar sorts of
things but if I go on the internet and
say spark doesn't work well for me the
only thing that happens is I don't get a
job right like if you show up and you
you buck conventional wisdom that these
systems are magical fairy dust that
makes things go fast you know it's like
showing up and saying I don't know how
to make C go fast I can't write fast C
programs people like ok thank you for
telling us that goodbye so it was sort
of nice to have people who didn't really
have anything in particular to lose show
up and like here's some data you know
you folks figure it out so we got a bit
of support for that and I'm sure there's
gonna be more responses people will
probably drag me over some calls
afterwards I'll add to the list and if
it turns out that I'm fundamentally
wrong I'm happy to happy to tell
everyone but I thought we'd go through
maybe a few more examples those those
results from 2014 are a bit stale by now
and the fundamental point back in 2014
wasn't that these systems are ik and are
never gonna get any better they're
absolutely gonna get better the theme
though of the work was more about you
know how do we evaluate them to make
sure that they get better like how do we
track the progress that's going out
these systems to make sure that we're
constantly either impressed or not yet
impressed with the current state of
affairs so that we can complain or not
complain you know sort of move people in
the right direction
so been tracking this as time goes on
here's some more recent work from from
Sigma in 2016 where people were looking
at
a data log people are familiar with data
log it's sequel with with recursive in
some sense with iteration built into it
and you can do you can do a bunch of
things but one thing that people often
like to do is graph traversal type
queries because you don't know ahead of
time how many joins you're gonna need to
do to actually fully explore some
relation or to derive all of the the
records you might derive so some folks
big data log is out of UCLA compared
with systems from in order Berkeley
Stanford University of Washington doing
data log style computations graph reach
ability in this case again fortunately
using the same number of cores as before
makes it easy some similar data sets
there's some bigger data sets too
they're off to the right of the screen
but you know again you can you can turn
on a laptop and try these things out and
you get I have one in two cores here for
good reason but you get times they're
basically competitive you didn't need
necessarily all of the complicated guff
there now I have one in two cores
because in this case it is just my
laptop but it's actually using a data
parallel framework that I'm playing with
as like a thing that I like making any
you know it's scales also so you know
one one to two looks like you're getting
a pretty good improvement and it'll
improve for a little while
beyond that we didn't actually measure
it out on 120 of course but the
framework has a really cool property
that I just wanna throw out there is
something that maybe you didn't realize
you could do which is that it
automatically incrementally updates
itself so you when did your reach
ability computation on some billions of
edges and someone comes along and
changes an edge how long does it take to
correctly update the the result and have
the new absolutely hundred percent
correct answer ready to go and in this
particular system tens of microseconds
which microseconds are not a unit that
usually gets thrown around in the big
data space but you know pretty pretty
brisk yeah so this is the sort of thing
that if we just if we took the lines up
above and said looks good to me I don't
know that we would be moving towards
these sorts of results and so I
um basically this is why I keep showing
up and putting these in people's faces
like here's some cool things that you
can do and I want you to want these
things not because you should want my
lap we can't stay away from my laptop
but you know if we're gonna move the
field forward if I could get better
infrastructure we're gonna need to ask
for it even more recently so vldb 2017
just happened a month or so ago in
Munich and there are several several
papers there but one of them was looking
at clique computation so you're
generally like motifs in graphs so you
know a clique okay those are fully
connected in this case graph on five
nodes there are other little motifs that
you can imagine you know just small
shapes basically on a graph so you want
to say in a larger graph tell me about
all the occurrences of this this little
pattern like I'm really excited to find
bowties or something like that in my
graph for five weeks because I think
that that maybe indicates a certain
social structure it's semantically
meaningful for some reason yeah what how
does that work and and we it's an area
that the databases and graph mining
people have been pursuing for a little
while
threw up some results in in the paper I
don't want to harsh on them too much but
you know they sort of been like okay
we're improving on the state of the art
previous algorithms and absolutely these
this is totally an improvement but of
course you know this you can write this
thing down again in ten lights on a
single thread and you got some numbers
and the first number wow that's that's
what I was expecting you're a lot faster
than this yeah because that's that's
your story the second number though is
absolutely worse than then the scalable
system so you know I do want to point
any like there are good reasons to use
lots of computers they can actually help
you do things do things faster we just
need to have some standards and some
expectations stuff like that
unfortunately I'm not the sort of person
who just sort of lets things go and so
my laptop actually has two cores two
physical cores and two hyper 30 of
course so you can you can turn them on
and this particular problem motif mining
paralyzes more or less trivial
you just sort of slice up
the responsibility for the different
outputs that you might produce give
everyone a copy of the graph and say go
and figure out those five clicks that
you know start with a node with ID mod 0
0 mod 4 1 mod 4 2 mod 4 3 mod 4 and the
work just paralyzes beautifully across
most support course
sorry beautifully paralyzes very simply
naively and as it happens it skills
scales pretty nicely
you could even go and do something we
did a sort of a hypothetical experiment
of what if I slice this thing up 160
ways no I don't have a laptop with 160
course yet because the amount of money
you have to pay Apple to get that is
yeah so what you can do though is slice
the slice to grab up 160 ways run
serially through these things and record
the maximum amount of time any of the
pieces took so had you distributed the
data and asked everyone do your work how
long does it take to do the work on each
of the 160s the computation and then
maximize and that number I think is an
excellent baseline for like how much
work should you actually have to do so
whether you can achieve this or not
don't know but if you don't achieve
these numbers you should have an
explanation of why right you should be
able to tell people hmm yeah well we
spent a while distributing the data or
you know we're missing out on something
else
this is a pretty good target though for
a naive algorithm these other systems up
above were introducing fancy new
algorithms very naive algorithm
literally ten tens of lines of code so
yeah I don't know I'm optimistic that
with data like this as long as the right
people put pressure back on the system's
implementers we can get towards these
these smaller numbers we're 42 most like
it's like interactive time scales right
like if you're actually doing that
instead of waiting for a half a minute
or something like that you could
actually get stuff back right away and
and actually interact with users in real
time
it'd be really cool
right so this a lot of the content I
struggle a bit cuz a lot of this
contents a bit of a bit of a downer
right from an academic point of view
it's great you've learned a lot about
the state of the world you've got some
new reference standards and stuff but
from people who are like huh
you know that's that's what I'm using
man
I hate you I thought I'd I try to have
some some slightly more optimistic
comments and this is not optimistic like
I can magically make things go faster
for you but I'd at least reveal some
progress that's been made in the world
I'm not necessarily because of the cost
work but but at the same time as the
cost to work and one can understand
perhaps how paying a bit more attention
to how quickly things run yeah could
have helped or you know I want to take
credit for it so I'll just show you cool
things that you can do now so we're some
data this is again from the original
cost paper this is 20 iterations of
PageRank rather than graph connectivity
the results are sort of similar to what
we saw for graph connectivity and that
the laptop is doing pretty well against
these these systems with the same
attention to detail sort of being aware
of what your computer is actually doing
using a programming language that
compiles down to you know two raw code
instead of you know byte code or
something like that you can put together
a system and we've been working on this
for a little while timely data flow
where you actually get a lot of the
solid performance benefits and these
numbers we actually look at the the
traces of these these numbers you're
seeing because we're saturating the
network connections and we're seeing
these numbers because the CPU has pinned
all of the time we can check and see its
l3 cache misses that's sort of
information you know we're really
running a program that's exercising the
computer quite well to the point that we
can look and see what's actually
happening computer wise does it line up
with our expectations which is great
this is like a great I find a great
place for me to be and where I can
really do performance debugging in my
program at the level of what is that can
be is the computer doing the thing I
want it to do yet as opposed to like
what are the knobs on the JVM I should
be setting please oh great JVM dady
hopefully some of you have had that
experience maybe not
I wouldn't want to wish that on you
sorry not hopefully you've had the
experience but I believe that that's
happened let me throw up another thing
um these aren't these aren't numbers but
it's a it's meant to be serve this
aspirational goal for what sorts of
things might you like to do here's a
stream of data it's uh it goes from so
from left to right and maybe they're
like really cool social signals that
come along the stream of data like like
people tweeting about things and people
tweeting about specific topics and maybe
they're tweeting at particular people so
there's a bunch of different
interactions and cues about about what's
going on here and there's some questions
that you know you can imagine being
posed like okay well what's it what's a
really popular hashtag in this stream
and I'm guessing that a lot of you are
like yeah look I I can know that that's
that's totally fine I know how to count
things word counts been around for a
while
so you know we can try to make it a bit
more interesting right what if you want
to do this
hashtag counting by the emergent social
structure in the graph like who's
communicating with whom and these
clusters that that structure defines
what's popular in each of them so rather
than asking you for males aged 18 to 49
you know some pre-canned
statistic you know this morning people
are talking about something on Twitter
apparently it's that there were good
people on both sides of the Civil War I
don't know if you were following Twitter
so so I'm guessing there may be two
connected components there people have
different opinions on that and you might
want to understand what's going on in
each of them separately independent of
you know the biological characteristics
of the people alright maybe you could do
that I mean this is this is what the
graph processing systems tell you you
can do what if you wanted to do this in
real time all right millisecond latency
so the moment that a thing happens on
what Twitter or you know the platform
that you're personally attached to you
want to know you want to see these these
tics happen right away you can do this
today you could do this in 2013
we've you know we've built systems that
do these sorts of things but but you
serve this right but you got to want it
right like you if you keep going around
just sort of downloading systems that
have you know mediocre performance and
saying that's good enough for me
I'm gonna I'm gonna call it you're not
gonna get to these really cool things
and that might be fine right I'm not
nuts suggesting that any of you should
feel should feel bad about not doing
this sort of thing but it but it's out
there right you can you know with just a
little bit of fighting and pushing you
can go and find these things and say I
demand this right like I'm tired of
whatever silly nonsense you've been
doing I want something either like this
or some other cool thing that you know
that a computer can do just doesn't do
it yeah so I guess as a theme systems
are getting better right like when you
look at certainly the academic
literature the systems are improving
their standards are improving they're
getting faster primarily in my
experience because we demanded it
primarily because like the cost paper
came out in people like oh Jesus I won't
be able to publish my next paper if it's
not faster than a laptop this specific
laptop and that was good that that all
of these well you know for one year the
systems conferences didn't publish a lot
of papers on graph processing so that
was my fault I'm pologize for that but
subsequently people absolutely had
baselines that were we've compared this
now to a single thread implementation
and it's it's better yeah so for sure
multiple computers can do more than one
computer but you gotta you gotta force
people to actually make that happen
and that's I guess that's where all of
you come in right you have to actually
look I'm tired of your nonsense I know
that there's a 10x just sitting there
please you know make that happen or I'll
do it myself
so I thought I'd close I think this is
just a fun quote and thank you I sort of
put it up just as a little bit of sass I
guess but basically you know like a
computer is a cool super-powerful sort
of thing and they can really do a lot
and it's sort of disappointing as an
academic to see people use computers
hundreds of computers to account for the
fact that they
don't know how to get that hundred ex
out of the computer itself and not that
everyone should be able to do that but
you want someone involved in building
your stack who knows how to get that
sort of performance out of the computer
itself so that you don't have to go and
spend money 100x investment on on your
computers hundred X like okay getting
hundred machines on Amazon is is fine
you know you can do that the second
hundred X is really expensive right if
you're planning on already using a
hundred machines like oh sorry we got
another hundred X on top of that ten
thousand machines pretty expensive you
know that's you you really want to think
a bit harder about how you can maybe
tune the the actual system at that point
all right so I'm gonna wind down with
that just throw up some random things
this is me on Twitter you're more than
welcome to type sassy things there at me
you might get sassy comments back you
gotta be ready for that Twitter is a
pretty officious place and all of this
content is also up up online just about
everything I've been doing for the past
few years has been totally open you can
go and you know if you want to try this
out on your own data not because I
recommend actually using this code to do
page ranking or graph connectivity but
if you want to say like well what should
I expect you can go grab the code try it
out there's a bunch of other stuff too
like a bunch of repos my favorite one is
the blog at the end basically you know
ongoing investigation of a bunch of
interesting topics sometimes stuff that
I'm doing but also quite a lot of
critiques of systems building and
current systems research that's going on
some of which will line up maybe with
your interests um which may have nothing
to do with what you're interested in but
hopefully at least as entertaining and
and delightful but I'll stop there my
understanding is that we have some some
minutes for for questions for feedback
you know get off the stage that sort of
thing
but if you do have questions I think the
right thing to do is to waggle your hand
around and we'll find out microphone for
you
there's sometimes wykel them very
aggressively so that so I understand
your concerns about scaling and I used
to do way back in the day when I was
first version 15 and it took forever to
get anything run on it compared to what
I could do on my laptop
but the thing that I gained from it was
me and all the other programmers like I
was working with now had a standard
framework that we could code against so
there was some loss in processing
efficiency but there was a gain in in
developer efficiency what is your
response to that that that seems like a
great point right there are a bunch of
other incidentals that come with using
common frameworks from an academic point
of view so to be very clear I'm an
academic I'm not a business minded
person so my gut reaction as an academic
is that's absolutely wonderful and a
great idea what does distributed
computing have to do with that right
like you could just as easily build a
common framework that is a bunch of
libraries that you link against using
whatever code base you want and you know
if you you can write a graph processing
API that that just uses a single single
not that you should but you know that
uses a single thread you get the same
benefits of great we have a common
infrastructure it happens that some
people have done that for you already
because they have a larger distributed
framework that they feel is exciting but
does that necessarily can't can we
decouple those two things of good
software engineering on the one hand and
using lots and lots of computers to melt
icebergs because polar bears are evil as
a separate concern so this is my
reaction to it like I'm not I'm not yet
convinced that big piles of computers
are fundamental for getting everyone on
board team
you could argue and I think it's the
saint's argument that what using ten
times the computers gets us is access to
a larger pool of developers right the
number of people who are writing C C++
trusts voiding a low-level type stuff
versus the number of people who are
comfortable with Python and Java and
whatnot like that they're very different
and
bringing in people from a Python
background is a great thing to be able
to do because these people have other
skills right they have you know data
science skills when you know people are
learning about screwing with registers
they were learning about statistics and
maybe you have to eat the 10 X or
hundred X to bring that skill set into
the into the team and that is absolutely
worth considering is that is that worth
it or you know should we bring someone
else in who can then work with them to
try to recall back that that overhead
there's a bit of a rambling I don't know
that I nailed that answer sorry so this
is a bit of a stupid question I don't
the follow-up is probably gonna be a
little less stupid oh but when you said
that you run something on spark for
example and it's 160 course I'm assuming
that means that the only thing running
on that spark cluster of 160 courses
you're one thing right so yeah so to be
clear these numbers are pulled from the
people who wrote these systems I'm sort
of trusting them that when they did the
measurements for their own system they
give themselves favorable conditions
they certainly didn't report otherwise
though I haven't double-checked with
them to make sure that they weren't just
screwing around but yes I believe that
they had they spun up typically these
are cloud instances so they'll spin up
you know the 16 machines with 8 cores
each on Amazon do some work there it's
very possible there's cross traffic
going on because these are virtualized
instances but so I mean that's what I
assumed the follow up question then is
so one of the reasons that I think
scalability is important personally is
that you have to if there's not one
thing going on in the system at once and
so your One Laptop well it would be
great to run one small fraction of an
aggregate that is important what we
really care about at the end of the day
is you know the daily reporting or what
the customer sees what data it sees and
that's not one thing that's a hundred
things and they all have to run
concurrently and they all have to be
able to come back with the result right
and so while I mean I guess the case
that you could make would be then let's
have
during sixty-one core instances and run
that and I think there's a really good
case for that rather than having like
these big bloated systems but yeah I
guess that that was just the question is
is that your recommendation have having
a bunch of tiny tiny one core systems
that one so I I mean you're basically
you've nailed my position but I want to
step back from saying that's my
recommendation I don't to make
recommendation I wanna make sure that
people at least consider that yeah if
you have to do a large scale fun graph
reporting type thing most of by the way
most of what I said has been about
graphs graphs are interesting and and
exciting to me but those are slightly
weird computations but if you need to do
something that could be better done or
as efficiently done even on a single
machine
yeah just spin up I mean you can get
Amazon instances that are not you know
spark or Hadoop or anything like that
you can just turn on a machine have it
run whatever code you want and enter a
you know and then you actually have 160
machines each doing their own thing as
opposed to 160 160 weight computations
fighting with each other so it's you
know it's worth understanding and
considering are you getting the thing
from scalability of the system that you
wanted where a task spawner is it's good
to have that be scalable it's
fundamentally different sort of if you
have under 960 utterly independent
computations yeah just do them
separately I I would say haloo yeah
that's me Frank
I think what I got from that your talk
was that um it's not it's not
necessarily about hey everybody use use
your laptop I think it's about like you
know if you want performance consider
the nature the problem you're trying to
solve and don't just throw machines at
it you know but if you're gonna throw
machines think about what you're doing
can you kind of like go into more detail
about like why it's so difficult to
solve like graph databases and a
distributed you know fashion using like
many machines like just go over some of
the challenges that sure
so graph competitions to me I mean
graphs graphs are a thing and maybe you
have graphs in your life and maybe you
know
they're one of the first types of
computations where the fundamental
operation takes a piece of data it has
two names in it and says I need data
from both of these things so I need some
data that was not initially co-located I
need to track both of these things and
then put them in the same place if we
were just doing something like like word
count or grep or something like that or
some sort of nice accumulative
computation we just rip through the the
data and are done there isn't the issue
of going and tracking down data
essentially using random access in
different parts of the computation and
this is something that has frustrated a
lot of the Big Data community where they
they started from MapReduce or so let's
say and you've been up through Hadoop
and spark and stuff they were still
largely missing the concept from
database of indices right where indices
are what let you get quickly a
particular piece of data out there
without dropping the entire terabyte on
the floor and then picking it up again
and rearranging it so architecture life
if you think about what you really want
your computer to do it would be doing
something slightly different than a
sequence of relatively coarse grained
batch computations right you'd rather
have something that was maintained a bit
more persistent state and was a bit more
interactive and that requires I guess
rethinking a bit of the classes of
computation so for example graph graphs
streaming is another example where if
you want millisecond time scale
latencies it's gonna be pretty tricky to
think of that as picking up your
terabyte of data re-indexing it in order
to serve back the one question a person
had so I think fundamentally there few
different types of computations that
didn't really match the requirements
that people initially imagined you if
you're Google you're like okay we want
to index the web we're gonna do that
once a day that's good enough for us and
as people try to move more and more of
their computations into these frameworks
they're pushing up basic against the
limitations of the frameworks and
throwing machines at it was the only
solution that the frameworks have right
there isn't there isn't another pressure
release valve in the systems for like
what if you want to I mean you can get
some duct tape and baling wire out and
you know a few other Apache products to
sort of stitch together a few indices
and key value stores and stuff like that
but the frameworks themselves advertise
you should just get more computers and
that works only so far
if the problem is fundamentally
mismatched to to the tool
[Music]